hi I'm Angie Greenup and I'm been bleed  and this is an Oscar and we're taking  this thing on a road trip across the  United States will come to you New York  and Chicago and Houston we're me all  over the map so you tell us where to go  you want to set your wedding will go to  your wedding Bar Mitzvahs funeral yes  crayons birthday you want to brighten up  a funeral this is the best way bring an  Academy Award right to you and by the  way if you come see us while we're out  on the road and the plea for some reason  decide you're worthy you're gonna get  tickets to join us in hollywood on the  oscar red carpet seeing all your  favorite stars walk right before your  very eyes follow us at Oscar road trip  on twitter oscar roadtrip calm will be  all over the country we'll see you soon  this picture with this okay hmm your  proposal absolutely how could she say  yes if you propose with an Oscar and you  know how could you say no you mean oh  yeah man you want the person to say yes